Y
SO MANY FLOATED LEE ZELDIN'S
NAME AS A POSSIBLE NEW HEAD OF
THE RNC.
JOINING ME NOW IS NEW YORK
CONGRESSMAN LEE SELDEN,
ALL RIGHT, CONGRESSMAN.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO PLAY COY
TONIGHT.
NO COY LEE, WE WANT THE STRAIGHT
SHOOTER LEE ZELDIN, THAT MANAGED
TO HELP FLIP ALL OF THOSE SEATS
IN NEW YORK?
WILL YOU RUN FOR RNC CHAIR, YES
OR NO?
>> RIGHT NOW I AM SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERING IT.
I HAVE NOT DECIDED, HOWEVER I'M
NOT A PROCRASTINATOR, SO I WANT
TO VERY QUICKLY DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT TO MAKE THIS RUN.
WHAT I DO KNOW IS THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY WITH THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
RETOOL AND TO TRANSFORM, BECAUSE
WE HAVE HIGH STAKES RACES COMING
IN '24 FOR PRESIDENT IN THE
UNITED STATES AND NEED TO ELECT
MORE REPUBLICANS TO THE HOUSE
AND SENATE WITH CANDIDATES WHO
NEED TO GET ELECTED AS WELL.
WHAT I DO KNOW FOR SURE IS THAT
I AM COMMITTED TO DOING
ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING IN MY
POWER TO ENSURE THAT WE SAVE OUR
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A COUNTRY THAT NEEDS TO
BE SAVED, AND I PLAN ON DOING MY
PART.
I'M VERY SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING A
RUN FOR CHAIR OF THE REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
>> Laura: WHAT FACTORS DO YOU
NEED TO STILL CONSIDER?
I MEAN, SEEMS LIKE YOU HAVE
THOUGHT ABOUT IT REALLY
CAREFULLY, SO AGAIN, WHY THE
HESITATION?
>> SO RIGHT NOW I HAVE BEEN
COMMUNICATING WITH THE RNC
DELEGATES, THEY ARE 168 OF THEM
WHO HAVE A VOTE.
MANY HAVE REACHED OUT
ENCOURAGING ME TO RUN, AND
THAT'S WHY WE ARE HERE AT THIS
POINT MAKING THIS ANNOUNCEMENT
AND HAVING THE CONVERSATION.
AND THEY NEED A MAJORITY VOTE.
AND CONTINUE WITH THE
STATUS QUO.
AND THE NATIONAL COMMITTEE
DELEGATES, WANT TO GO IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
AND HAVE AN IMPORTANT ROLE TO
PLAY, AND THE MESSAGING AND
COMMUNICATIONS WITH FUND-RAISING
AND EXPENDITURES WITH ENSURING
THAT ITS ORGANIZATION AND
COLLABORATION, YOU HAVE TO LOOK
AT ELECTION INTEGRITY.
CANDIDATE RECRUITMENT AND
ENSURING THAT WHEN YOU'RE TRYING
TO CREATE A MOVEMENT, ENERGY AND
ENTHUSIASM COMING HAFTED NOT
JUST SAY WHAT YOU ARE AGAINST,
WE ARE AGAINST JOE BIDEN AND
AGAINST THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
OKAY.
BUT WHAT ARE YOU FOR?
EXACTLY.
AND WHAT WE ARE FOR IT IS
EXPRESSING TO THESE AMERICANS
THAT WE WANT TO DO EVERYTHING IN
OUR POWER TO SAVE AMERICA WHILE
THESE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER TO
SAVE THEMSELVES.
THERE ARE ATTACKS RIGHT NOW ON
SECURITY.
WE SEE IT AT OUR BORDER AND IN
OUR CITIES AND HAS NOW SPILLED
INTO THE SUBURBS.
ATTACKS ON WALLETS AND
RESTRICTION ON OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PROSPERITY.
ATTACKS ON OUR EDUCATION, AND WE
HAVE TO REVERSE.
>> Laura: RON McDANIEL IS
RUNNING FOR ANOTHER TERM OF RNC
CHAIR, AND SHE ARTIE SAID THAT
SHE HAS THE SUPPORT OF I GUESS
100 OR SO OF THE RNC MEMBERS, SO
DO YOU THINK SHE DESERVES
ANOTHER TERM?
HOW DO YOU RATE HER PERFORMANCE?
>> WELL, SHE DOESN'T HAVE 100, I
MEAN, THAT IS CLEAR FROM ALL THE
CALLS I HAVE BEEN RECEIVING AND
THINK THAT THAT WAS A MASSIVE
ROUNDING UP.
I HAVE WORKED WELL WITH RHONDA,
WE HAVE GOTTEN ALONG WELL.
I AM A MILITARY GUY COMING IN OH
COMING PUT SOMEONE IN A POSITION
FOR TWO, THREE, FOUR YEARS, THEY
START DOING A FANTASTIC JOB AND
YOU PROMOTE THEM, AND MOVE THEM
TO SOME OTHER JOB AND YOU BRING
A NEW IDEAS, NEW ENERGY AND
FRESH PERSPECTIVE.
I HAPPEN TO BE SOMEBODY IN FAVOR
OF TERM LIMITS.
I'M LEAVING THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AFTER FOUR TERMS
IN EIGHT YEARS AND I BELIEVE
THAT OUR FOUNDING FATHERS INTENT
WAS THAT YOU COME TO CONGRESS,
YOU BRING YOUR IDEAS AND YOUR
ENERGY AND TRY TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND THEN YOU MOVE ON.
I THINK THEY'RE SO MUCH TO
BENEFIT FROM UNDERSTANDING YOU
CAN BE PERFECT.
>> Laura: WHEN CAN WE EXPECT A
DECISION FROM YOU?
>> THIS IS SOMETHING WE WANT TO
FIGURE OUT IN A MATTER OF DAYS,
THIS ISN'T A A MATTER OF WEEKS.
>> Lau